[Musica]
[Risate]
che cos'è questo più un ristorante sì ma
non è un ristorante normale guardate
bene
no guarda bene la pace sembra normale
non credo che abbiamo cucinato cose
normali da mangiare per le e infatti
oggi dovremmo scappare da un mister
scherick dai nel recente al ristorante
un lusso cuoco chef cattivo non voleva
vedere per tempo posso mangiare pochi
come quello di digitare è super
emozionato per la chiusura vedere più
cibo c'è qua dentro ma secondo me
nemmeno ci sarà il cibo
[Musica]
non mi piace
premio
eccoci qua fusione tra anita
che cosa è successo
vi piace il mio luogo auschwitz giallo e
poi ho messo delle orecchie ta volte
maggiore
ehi ma si temono sono qui
qualcosa di strano io ti vedo un fermo
qua e mobile abbinare che succede posso
quindi agro che sto prendendo siena
perché ci
sono bloccato io nel frattempo vado a
mangiare thao lo prendo per lavorative
non sarà la maledizione di questo
ristorante spero per come mi sono
sbloccato finalmente la maledizione del
panino
se va bene perché informativi li prendo
servono per le patatine ti sconsiglio di
distrarti bevi stanno già linea da
spegnersi le luci
credo che così facendo siamo rimasti su
come sta per ventola padella a sostare
non devi fermarti a controllare
qualsiasi cibo perché altrimenti rimarrà
indietro non resta celato rifondere chi
mangerà capitato abbiamo il bottone
risolviamo tutti su un secondo voi
evitare riuscire a sopravvivere fino
alla fine dell'escape room vorresti
sfracellare a 10.000 volte secondo me
basta solo che mangio pochettino poi
dopo il resto è bravo
trarre dal cibo tra stai già volando
vedi no sei tu che sta volando dove
abbiamo ridotto lo scritto di istruzione
o no forse era una trappola dello chef
ma non dovevamo prendere laciare
dovevamo andare dalle scale non lo so o
no se siamo molti stanno aprendo tutto
sentiamoci siamo qui
dovete sono qui
non ti vedo intrappolato in un altra
dimensione può essere aiuto ecco insomma
il capitale che corre abbiamo perso la
[Musica]
t6 sfrotunata il primo stralcio
allenamento basse
e colori momento c'è qualcosa di molto
strano in queste sky forum o poi è
completamente bagnata e non funziona
niente ai vedovi che sei berlina tati
vedo su ok ragazzi
[Musica]
cè un congelamento
dice forse qualcosa di stranissime poi
perché provo ogni tanto si banca ma
l'importante è prendere ben prima di
evitare che già mi ha superato da juba
ora ora su un gran gelato da quelle nave
verrei affettato non direi proprio per
non è stata dettata l'ultimo aiuto di a
poi saviano ok che cosa
dice di continuare da questa basta ok
abbiamo
già preso fuoco
sì credo che bisogna scappare
noi nel peso di lugo ma è tutto dritto è
questo
aspetta aspetta il successo qualcosa
fuori successo sono ritornate via da
fare
anche aspetti sull'inceneritore questa
di como dal fuoco quindi io salgo le
scale aspettami successo ti aspetto qui
sopra in cui si aspettava faccia gigante
della bombola giorgio padrin cota se si
pensa di sopra le scale le scale animato
prima che c'è mancato poco sono nate
così stanno le buco aiuto il cubo guarda
guarda cosa ho messo nel pavimento
quello pre restar margini in anita
evitare macina bagnino che immaginate
che bisogna yuto e poi c'e la sua testa
gigante
mi ha macinato fatto la pasta
mista per me sta sbagliando tutto siamo
proprio tritatelo a meno del giusto
di roma
e lo sapevo che sarebbe morto tante
volte in queste sì che il rum poi una
domanda non creare troppo ma se c'è il
ketchup la sera per questo ha detto è
che cos'è
essere la salsa verde percorso meta
maturate mai può essere invasi libico
sono avanti
eh sì perché ministra palazzi peccato
contro venivi triturato ora quindi non
vediamo mangiati dalla testa e lo so
siamo in questo posto potrà non ci sono
dei teschi e sono gli altri giocatori
che ho a che fare con degli spuntoni
sono riuscito a passare però ha preso
motivi estetici che ha un nuovo perdiamo
il diritto a settimana temi sentiti sono
passato sarà tantissimo da ieri da
sbrilli spetta l'ultimo bagno
non si passato è cosa credete che
andiamo a chi cazzo ho visto che il cibo
cava veramente poco per spiace curtis
vediamo se vitale cadrà ma certo che no
non è mancato poco per ogni volta che
dico vediamo se vitamina k sono qui alla
fine dell'anno del ponte ti aspetto qui
per prendermi futuro
così riuscirò a superare questo punto
evo letto se io mi metto qui ad esempio
nome 32 stai passando il ponte e
cominciò a saltare sul forte per farlo
vibrare tutto che ne pensi non credo che
funziona infatti noi facciamo
federalismo e facciamo vedere rita
lanciano bisogno guarda vitale mi ha
contagiato mi ha contagiato lo
spazzolamento perenne
gli ultimi mancano solo gli ultimi di
aiuto cuoco mi sta inseguendo devi
correre velocissima e trovare la strada
altrimenti lui ti prende ma già preso ma
che è brutto perché codice date
schiacciare così intenzioni
ok riproviamo da che parte devo andare
il problema che un tavolo tra la
dirigenza è
stata chiamata come fatto sfracellati
aiuto aiuto aiuto cerchiamo la via
d'uscita prima garlini
e trovato qualcosa si è tuttavia sta
così sono titoli giusti
non è possibile che siamo troppo corti
l'ultimo piamente peraltro evitare ora
credo che torneremo al che lo di sopra
io sono già so che sto salendo con
l'ascensore introduce remo in economia
spendere quindi superato d'italia vista
che ora torniamo in cucina così vita si
trascinerà più voluto vederci bergamo
c'è lo slime qualche collo dalle pareti
ma che cos'è questo tipo unico una
stanza con questa sera degli esperimenti
di
[Applauso]
chi non c'è niente no aspetta guarda
bene
sindaco basso ci sta guardando che
lavori spiega la luce qualcosa mi dice
che alla fine di questo quadro ci sarà
lui che ci aspetta se sei diventato da
qualche presente invece stavo per dire
di tre medialità no il bene dobbiamo
prenderlo io prima sistri certo certo
come no lo prendi doveva tanto sono in
vantaggio adesso tanto lo so che anni
d'acquisto nocella sempre quindi posso
andare a fare magari molto tranquillo
allora vediamo qui ci sono questa specie
di tombini che sparano aria calda che
metteva in che il canto sembra tipo
furono vapore figlio tahiti aspetto di
specialità
possibilmente arriva tutta intera per
farlo
dobbiamo usare la zip line
[Musica]
wow super divertente questa porta della
bellissima ma dobbiamo saltare adesso
non lo so forse 19enne tela minuto wow
siamo passati
siamo passati attraversamenti appena
sveglio quelle sono piante carnivore
piante carnivore abbiamo tante le piante
carnivore ma poi tocca anche il ragazzo
prima che si chiudano spendete cardillo
che si mangiano certo so che divora
quindi devi saltare velocissimamente
vedi il tuo
23 gen fatta così struttura di sale e
cosa c'entra questa ragno temo è perché
ci diranno se c'è i serpenti vogliono
cdm iran ma cosa c'entra con
mai fatto un bel salto cosa c'entra con
il ristorante con il cuoco un abito
bisogna mandare sui bordi del regnatela
sì certo su ball un albero no hanno dato
moltissimo
albero roberto qualche a casa in questo
game room
io infatti sono venuto qui perché era
del cuoco e perché sapevo che si poteva
mangiare invece non c'è nessuno che
pensi attenti i ragni le ragnatele degli
alberi e solo il poco che vuole mangiare
guardate che cos'è questo ma vitale
bisogna fare sfracellato un viaggio o
chi realmente resta una piscina sembrava
tipo di un portale fatto politica perché
ci sono io di casa
sono riusciti a scappare può essere un
badge io gigante era un bell'uomo
gigante tra un belgio
eccoci così come il gruppo di prima era
molto molto breve timore in un altro
ristorante una volta cibo vero volto ora
questo sandwich e questo proprio questo
nome la gina bella giulia ma era un
augurio
che si aspetta in questo o se clicchi
nella venati da un pezzo ebbene nascosta
nei prati sei assi reato anche qua
sembra gli occhi cattivi
vediamo cosa troveremo questi problemi
ma già allora tristi entrare attraverso
questo sfiato più anche qua con
tranquillità
come la strada giusta
allora io seguirò te perché tu sei più
bravo di tutto il trucchetto vediamo
quale riusciamo a stare qui c'è un ma
lascia no dovrebbe essere questa no hay
aspettiamo me non ha funzionato
ok poi quella centrale no
e allora sarà quell'altra vediamo
ne manca solo uno adesso
sarà quella centrale io dico di sì ma
non è tutto ok era quella di
traffico kay salvaggio cosa questo
baccano teatro colosseo
[Musica]
guarda che poi raddoppiare il salto ne
avrei bisogno in questa fase ok quindi
vuol dire che dobbiamo saltare da un
punto lontano o o ma qui vediamo dove lo
aspetta ti devi saltare due volte presto
da qui faccio no sono un partito
limitano si ancora social lato mi sono
stato io ecco qua vitale vediamo se
riesce a fare doppio salto vediamo
che cosa è successo un fatto normale
dopo quadrille vedo più alto ma io
stiamo facendo un salto normale sei
bianco ma ciò che ne esce adesso prova
vediamo è stato normale
ok allora solo dinos altro
fortissimo piano non cadere perché
dovrei chiedere
doppio fatto ho visto brava
passato evviva siamo bravissimi troppo
non è vero che cosa è successo qui è
caduto le due big strone il passaggio di
verdure
nelle parti bianca e andò visite
doppio pato
sono riuscito a passare ok riproviamo
sua figlia che è vitale mi ha superato
e ora da che parte vado vado margherita
si giochi a salto brava l'ultimo mi
raccomando questo
però si è fatta
ehi allora dove sei di qui sono qui per
dare in questo buco sappiamo
siamo tipo
mai che qualcuno c'entra niente con una
cosa che posso fare
è forte la bocciatura testa non lo so
vedi c'e un giorno scalino abbiamo dato
mandato d'ora in poi essere ho sempre
fatto quando non serve per divertente
loro d'ordine non
sono curioso di vedere cosa c'é negli
altri ribelli verso che fino ad oggi
drago niente questo è il livello lattuga
mandati prima che a livello era il
livello salse salsa livello lattuga e
adesso che cosa che cosa significa che
se la supervelocità no non c'è io sto
d'altopiano strano forse si sono
dimenticati di aggiungermi aggiunto
nella super velocità che resterà quella
roba verde la foto troppo
marco lo sia adesso funziona la
superamento battere la striscia gialla
che avevano almeno dobbiamo saltare
piene di tasche nastrino giallo per foto
che si sbracci della fame vediamo
vediamo come stai attenta la
supervelocità volevo dire che stai
pericoloso perché ti fanno pagare
mancate
ricorda che puoi utilizzare il doppio
salto e io so ricorda
che si porta lo salva da adesso si sono
passato il portale della natura e che
dobbiamo saltare anche bene sei tornate
ristorante niente
allora
la scacchiera
ma che c'entrano la vas e prima stavamo
facendo con la lattuga riportare la fuga
il pianeta delle salse e adesso dobbiamo
vitale fare da specchietto
brava
[Risate]
io non ho parole ok basta questa volta
ce lo farò non ci credo che era stata
vista sfracellato
l'ultimo da juventino
non sono fare
the slide ok cambia ma ce l'ho fatta
liberal ben 15 volte
allora si poteva scegliere la porta
giusta non scegliere la porta sbagliata
ve lo ricordate no credo che dobbiamo
fare il doppio salto a tutto il quinto
l'altro non ho fatto il doppio salto
nobili ha anche tutti 6 sfracellata sono
davvero nato sono ancora noti
ok ciao a vita non scrivere questa è la
parte giusta e allora questa chiusa
quindi abbiamo da qui
no non ti sei sono fermata
quando entro in questa volta non correre
non costano cari amici
perché quando si entra nelle porte sia
tra piano sia allora è stranissimo
questa volta entrò pianista e allora via
bra
adesso doppio salto dove stato bravo
adesso doppio salto ancora di la lohan
che
[Musica]
hai preso la rivalità non ci posso
credere
è diventata me piano piano
ok adesso sia bravo doppio salto
doppio salto e poi lo vedo più stare no
no no no poi prima del respiro e poi
prodotto tanti
[Musica]
prendono l'auto normale ok
dobbiamo sanare con un cucchiaio per
dove 1 è carino
guardate il cuoco c'è scatti voli che
sta facendo noi così via saltiamo sul
pomodoro no aspetta aspetta e cioè senza
qualcosa che non doveva far parte degli
ingredienti della zucca potete più
andare adesso so
è un ragazzo sul pomodoro sul pomodoro
funziona ok pomodoro ok pomodoro sia
no aspetta forse questo pomodoro e
facendomi anche visto al vostro gelando
lo sicuro che mi stava annoiando un po
lo hai sbagliato
[Musica]
no
non funziona
[Musica]
ragazzi non so perché ma abbiamo dovuto
fare salta fate perché poi si straccia
le vamos era prete era un bug forte è
detto anche qui ci sono dobbiamo
nemmeno io nel
salto doppio salto doppio voto ci hai
fatto e wt velocissimi ok però doppio
salto proprio salto
doppio ha promesso roma 28 ce l'ho fatta
sono posta sulla facciata li 44 dove c'è
una piccola scala segreta dobbiamo
saltare farà poco dove andremo solo nel
frigo o
non venire devo mangiare tutto parlacino
il primo ma che ma che freddo
non fa bisogna salire sopra il frigo o
no mi sono solo dell'atto sono centra
dalla lavato capa e volevo esplorare
venga offerta non è breve
siamo il bagno
questo bagno a
pagare dai preso bevuto le piastrine che
abbiamo ma siamo stati tutti i giri di
questa volta il più possibile
e come tale che casa al gabinetto ok non
le fognature giustamente nella fognatura
ci sono i toast le fette di pane da
toast aree prima di
prima di strano
priva di evitare per leggere gli ultimi
quadri quindi domenica i pannelli
fotovoltaici qua sono diventati jolly
che cosa è successo io vivo dopo la
premiere del peggio non bisogna evitare
le macchine e stai attenta a non essere
schiacciata dalle macchine sono ferme e
non abbiamo ucciso mai metti che
all'improvviso si mettono a muoversi da
creta siamo usciti dal ristorante
temo il peggio motivo il belgio
discobar ce la possiamo fare
no no no sono qui dietro di te
vicinissimi
vedete il badge è laggiù devo
assolutamente prenderlo e vitale st
primario di evitare rimborso io
mangiavano da evitare andato di nuovo
no non me lo dire guarda non mi dire che
ho trovato al peggio non ci credo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
va bene che questa volta ha visto su
perché esistono più brava io mi sono
giocato fin troppo a volte con i
commenti vi è piaciuto più la prima e si
propone la stefanescu drum e ora vi
lasciamo con quattro mesi il cane primo
dei nostri altri video quella che
preferite buona visione ciao